Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. I want to do a short video on why we would recommend Cyrex testing
There's other laboratories. I'm not just stuck on Cyrex labs, but there's other laboratories that will do antibody testing
Eat as well
Cyrex does it well in my book. I think they do it the best. That's why we use them when we test for antibodies
So a little explanation of what we're testing for
So an antigen
Is something that the immune system is trying to kill
so
Back up a little bit you have two different ways that you get rid of
Things in your body that aren't supposed to be there. You have your immune system and you have your detoxification pathways
Now typically
Pesticides and chemicals and heavy metals and such are supposed to be
gotten rid of
Through your detoxification pathways, but in the case of you being overwhelmed by a toxin
You are exposed to a lot of pesticides or something like that. Then you can end up
Having an immune reaction against it when you have an immune reaction against it
You can create antibodies
So an antibody is a protein that is produced by the immune system in response
To the presence of an antigen
That's the definition of an antibody
But an antigen is anything that's in the body that's not supposed to be there now. I said
Pesticides and chemicals and things are supposed to go through your detox pathways, but we're exposed to so many of those things
It's not uncommon that we can create antibodies against them because they're prolonged in the body
in the bloodstream in the tissues that because our immune because our detox pathways are overwhelmed
The good thing to do is to read my seven phases of detox book here
Your immune system is supposed to make antibodies against
viruses and bacteria and
Pathogens that are killable because that's what your immune system does your detoxification pathway gets rid of chemicals and
Non-living things your immune system gets rid of living things bacteria
viruses pathogens
Micros that are trying to reproduce in your body make it a home and use you as a host
That's what your immune system is supposed to do and your immune system will create antibodies to do that
So that's what we're looking for are you
Invertedly is your immune system inadvertently created antibodies against things that it shouldn't create antibodies against and then worst-case scenario
Are you creating antibodies against your own cells against your own tissues against your own organs that?
Is what's called an autoimmune disease if you're making antibodies against your thyroid that's measurable
We can measure TPO antibodies and you have anti, you know, excess antibodies against your thyroid
You have Hashimoto's or Graves disease and at what state you're in so it's that's what we're looking for when we're looking at antibodies
So briefly when chemicals come into your body they go into your cells and
Your immune system will fire or reaction against it typically you'll have it what's called a TH1 response first and then it can't kill it because it's not
killable and
Then you have a TH2 response if you're if you're detoxification pathways can't get rid of it that you have the
The B cell response and you start to make antibodies against this thing
That's what we're talking about with your immune system. That's a normal response of your immune system in the in the presence of an
Antigen that is a living organism
You have a TH1 response in order to kill this pathogen and it's not able to kill the pathogen and
a period of time goes by and now you have a TH2 response to create antibodies so it can take the pathogen
That's what an antibody does it takes the pathogen so that now when you have a TH1 response
They're your T cells and your macrophages and
Your natural killer cells are able to find it easier and kill it
That's a whole purpose of antibodies, but if you're making antibodies against yourself tissue, you're destroying self-tissue
If you're making antibodies against
Mercury or lead or a pesticide
Your immune system will fire to kill it while those things aren't killable. They're not living to organisms
So you just create this inflammatory response and an upgrade of
Inflammation of your body. That's one major reason why people have chronic inflammation that chronic inflammation is because
They have antibodies to things that aren't killable like foods or chemicals
So every time their immune system fires you're going to try to kill that which you have antibodies for and
If it's not killable, you just have this ramped up inflammation
So it's a good idea to try to test for those
Here's a picture of making antibodies against a virus. This is actually I think a picture of the coronavirus or something like that that somebody drew up
But you make antibodies against it so it tags the virus or the bacteria so that now it's more
Recognizable by the killer cells the macrophages. So you want antibodies against
Bacteria and viruses. That's really the definition of a healthy immune response. I have a really healthy immune system
What does that mean? Well, it really means I have a lot of antibodies against a whole bunch of different pathogens
So next time somebody says do you have a healthy immune response say yes, I have a lot of antibodies against a whole bunch of pathogens
But we don't want to have a lot of antibodies against non-living things and we certainly don't want to have antibodies
Against our old tissues. So that's what we want to measure. We want to measure. Do I have antibodies against non-living things or my old tissues?
That's what an antibody test is
Cyrex does that well and they have a lot of tests. That's really all they do is measure antibodies
That's what that lab does. They have a lot of different tests that they call arrays
So here's a couple of them. The one on the left here is their food
Sensitivity test it measures. It's called array 10 hit measures a lot of different things
So 300 different things cooked and raw foods and vegetables that you might not even
Feel like you have a tummy ache with when you eat, but you have antibodies against them
Circulated your bloodstream because it isn't blood test that every time you do eat them
You fire a reaction you cause more inflammation and more just this whole negative cycle of inflammation takes place
And it can cause pain it can cause problems all over your body
Array 11 is the chemical autoimmune reaction
Screen so it's measuring afflatoxins different types of molds and what is produced by molds and what is produced by bacteria from
aldehyde a whole bunch of different chemicals that were exposed to in our environment
That that that we really shouldn't be exposed to or we should be
excreted but because we're exposed to so many different chemicals our immune system or our detoxification pathways get overwhelmed and
They these chemicals linger in our body our immune system tries to kill them
And of course they can't because they're not there be things and then we are B cell or our TH2
System fires we had have created antibodies against things. We never should have created antibodies against and this causes a lot of
Problems in health wise. There's a joint autoimmune reaction screen. It's tested for arthritic peptides and collagen complex and
There's a neurological autoimmune reactive screen
This is a very serious one because if you have antibodies to your cerebellar cells
That is a major problem
So we see that a lot with chronic Lyme patients that have a lot of
brain fog and can't think straight and they have pain and all sorts of different areas
Well, you could have damaged
Microglial cells and you really should watch their video in this
in this module on microglial priming and
Influ- a neurological inflammation because that goes into detail of
Damaged microglial cells are primed microglial cells. That's a brain cell. That is responsible for the immune reaction of the brain
But once we have antibodies to the brain to brain different tissue, then it's even more serious
So this is a major issue why people have cognitive problems why people have just all sorts of
Any you have you have antibodies to certain parts of your brain
It can cause pain anywhere it could cause
Sensitivity issues it can cause the weirdest array of symptoms and then there's a pathogen associated immune reactivity screen for all sorts of different pathogens
so
You have excess amounts of these things. It can be a major issue and then a array five is that multiple autoimmune
reactivity screen. Now these are all blood tests. So you'd have to get a kit and you have to find a place where you can get a draw
So getting this drawn and sent into Cyrex once you get the data back. It's very easy to read
You don't need me or a doctor to really to go over the test with you
But what you need is what am I going to do about it now and we'll have videos about that
In this module as well
What do I do what I have antibodies two different things?
Well, it's really easy to understand. What do I do if I've antibodies to food? Well, I just have to have to stay off at those
But we'll have videos about that as well because I have different recommendations for that
Remember, why do we test for antigens because of my cardinal rule
When you fire an immune response for whatever reason I take a whole bunch of immune stimulants
I'm gonna fire an immune response. I have a cold. I'm gonna fire an immune response. I'm exposed to strap
I could fire an immune response
When you do that your immune system will attack and kill many times that would you have antibodies against first?
Of course, I won't kill if you have antibodies against a chemical
But if you have antibodies against self-tissue
aka an autoimmune disease and you are taking a whole bunch of immune stimulants
You are gonna be killing that tissue. That's why
If you have an autoimmune disease, you have no business taking immune stimulants on a regular basis
You just don't so even if you have like high of Hashimoto's
But I feel like I'm coming down with something and I'm getting sick
Well, you can take immune stimulants to help your body kill that virus or bacteria that you're being exposed to
You feel like you're coming down with something different but you won't better not be taking it on a regular basis
Taking immune stimulants on a regular basis will fire an immune response
And if you have antibodies against self tissue, you are going to be killing yourself
So I hit this over and over again in a bunch of the videos where we talk about autoimmune line
I just can't say it enough. So that's why we look for antibodies
That's why you want to look for antibodies and tests for antibodies
So you know what you're dealing with so you know how to move forward
That's always a good thing to do. We'll have more videos on this so
Keep looking back at this site and this module because we'll be continued to add more stuff
Thanks so much. I'll be praying for you. Bye bye